Bonjour, je...
Pardon? Ça fait trop mois que tu n'as pas mis un pied sur ta chaîne YouTube et tu arrives comme ça comme une fleur ?
Bah désolé en fait je vous explique...
Ouais j'espère que tu as une bonne excuse?
Bah justement, à ce propos..
Quoi? Ton chat a eu un rhume ? Tu t'es cassé un ongle ? Je t'écoute
Non c'est pas ça, en fait heu...
bah j'ai créé la vie en fait
AH !
(Chante)
Meilleure excuse au mooonde
Bon. je suis très heureux et très fier de vous annoncer que...
ça y est j'suis papa
j'suis papa putain
c'est un truc de ouf
Je sais même pas par où commencer tellement le truc est énorme
En tout cas voilà je crois que j'ai jamais été aussi heureux de toute ma vie
hein Heu..
j'en suis sûr même
Bravo à la maman qui a participé beaucoup au projet quand même
Bon je dors plus la nuit hein mais au moins sa justifie mes cernes
pour une fois
Eh ouais, maintenant je suis responsable d'un petit être vivant n'importe où n'importe quand
*pleurs bruyants de bébé*
Excusez moi je....
Boujouboujouboujoubjou !
*rire* excusez moi.
ç'est marrant quand j'ai commencé des vidéos je vous parlais de jouer au ping pong
qui aurait cru que huit ans plus tard
*woosh woosh woosh woosh...*
Premièrement vous seriez toujours là
que je vous parlerai d'avoir un bébé??
C'est ouf la vie
Bon !
bah générique !
*claquement de doigts*
*musique tranquille*
*gazouillement de bébé*
J'suis pas le premier à avoir un bébé hein
J'ai regardé sur google
C'est marrant y a un chiffre pour ça
107 milliards 602 millions 760...
c'est je sais pas lire ce chiffre...mais ça fait beaucoup hein
bah plus un du coup *rire*
Même si ce chiffre est énorme chaque naissance et unique et vécue différemment
Heu, moi je suis personne pour parler au nom de tous les parents
hein donc heu...
Je vais simplement partager ma petite expérience personnelle
Et encore un petit extrait parce que tellement de trucs à dire...
Alors, par rapport au bébé.
beaucoup me demande son prénom,
son sexe
son numéro de sécu...
Mais comme je tiens quand même à ma vie privée et au respect de son anonymat
dans la vidéo mon enfant sera incarné
*woosh*
par lui
Plutôt réaliste hein ?
Ah oui, sur la miniature le bébé c'est un bébé issu d'une photo libre de droits
hein donc heu...
Je sais pas qui c'est...
Peut-être qu'un jour ses parents vont se promener sur youtube et faire :
-Avoir un béb...
Mais c'est notre fils !
Bon quand t'as un bébé ton mode de vie change complètement
Tu reset toute ta vie
C'est presque une deuxième vie qui commence
Maintenant mon bruit préféré c'est celui ci  :
"BURP !"
Ah bravo ! Oui !
Yes !
Mon style vestimentaire, j'en ai clairement plus rien à foutre
Norman?
t'as mis mon legging là
Ah ouais
Et il est où le bébé là ?
Oh la vache ! Hop là !
Tiens. Je me disais aussi
retire ce legging c'était celui de l'épisio de quoi maintenant pour sortir je prends le strict minimum
allez on va acheter une baguette OUHOU !!
avec la maman on n'a jamais été aussi proches
ça te dirait qu'on ai aucun rapport sexuel
grave "CLAP"
je découvre de nouveaux problèmes existentiels
aucun message
dormir est devenu parfaitement impossible
OUAINNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNN
OUAINNNNNNNNN
J'suis tellement fatigué que je fais n'importe quoi
Norman c'est pas pour moi là
ah ouais ouais ouais
comme  beaucoup de parents je suis persuadé que ma bouche est aseptisante et la titine qui tombe par terre
c'est pas possible ça
Voilà là c'est propre
Plus moyen d'être discret en public
mais c'est pas vrai
moi à la base je les connais pas je ne sais pas qui c'est moi, c'est pas ma famille
Et mes plus belles victoires sont pas forcément celles que j'imaginais 5 jours qu'il est constipé
ahhhhh génial oh mon dieu mais c'est excellent oui génial !!
Ah ouais c'est de la merde ouais
Après c'est un mode de vie en quelques mois j'ai appris des milliers de choses
déjà j'ai appris que les nouveau nés les premiers mois bah ils voient flou et en noir et blanc
ouais il nous voit comme sa voit comme ça ouais
j'ai aussi appris que par exemple les nouveau nés ils ont différents types de pleurs
qui correspondent à différents signaux un type de pleurs pour dire qu'il a faim un type de pleurs pour dire qu'il a froid etc
et j'avoue qu'au bout d'un moment
tu reconnais les nuances et tu deviens un peu expert
tu veux ton biberon, pas de problème tiens
Voilà ça va mieux la couverture je comprends il fait un peu froid
Voilà on est bien mieux là
c'est clair le dernier épisode de game of thrones nul à chier abusé ah ouais ouais non mais c'est ah ouais ouais mais c'est clair
l'accouchement c'était fort
Je me rappelle j'arrive à la maternité un petit peu en retard
et j'ai vu cette sage-femme sortir avec ce tout petit être humain
Je me suis approché
nos regards se sont croisés pour la première fois et c'est à cet instant que j'ai vraiment le sentiment d'être père
et puis la sage femme m'a dit
Le vôtre il est côté monsieur
Ah bon ? Il me ressemble un peu quand même
Quand tu viens d'avoir un bébé en plus de vivre un truc extraordinaire
j'imaginais pas mais tout le monde te félicite, t'offre des cadeaux, t'es au centre de l'attention au max limite c'est ton anniversaire
"Bravo mec" oh mais non tu déchires merci
Félicitations pour ton bébé.
Mon quoi?
le bébé
merde!
OH OH putain oh le con
être parent ça rend forcément responsable, t'es responsable d'un
d'un si petit truc si fragile tu peux pas faire le truc à moitié et en tant que papa tu prends ta mission très à coeur
enfin tu deviens quelqu'un d'autre ça a presque un côté un peu viril
je serais prêt à donner ma vie pour la sienne
Ma devise elle est simple : allier force et précision, les coups et blessures me font plus rien, il ne faut rien laisser au hasard
On m'appelle le professionnel, cette guerre c'est la mienne : celle d'un père
Tu as beau avoir une petite déco style et chez toi quand tu as un nouveau-né ya rien à faire
ta maison devient inévitablement une garderie toi tu te transformes
en nounou quand t'organises une soirée chez toi soyons honnêtes, c'est plus vraiment comme avant
frère ça vas ou quoi
polala elles sont où les meufs ce soir on se pète le crâne
On chuchote s'il vous plait, on se lave les mains pour les microbes on enlève les chaussures bon pas d'alcool mais pour la musique j'ai tout prévu
Bah quoi ma soirée elle vous plaît pas bah enfait ç'est pas trop une soirée mec tu nous a fait venir à 14 heures
et enfin l'un des moments les plus durs pour moi c'est le moment où tu confies ton enfant pour la première fois
à un ou une baby sitter c'est assez difficile bon ben voilà on rentre dans deux trois heures à peu près
on a confiance en vous alors un petit regard au revoir
Un petit bisou aussi
Aller
Oui on va faire comme ça merci en tout cas on fait vraiment confiance
merci beaucoup hein bonne soirée ta tout ta le linge les couches
Bref je plaisante sur les petits tracas quand t'as un nouveau né la maison
et je vous assure que je vis la plus belle période de ma vie je vous souhaite à tous de vivre ça un jour
de mon côté il me reste plein de trucs à découvrir, la vie de papa elle est sans fin
bon j'avoue que je me suis pris une petite pause paternité pendant quatre mois
mais ne croyez pas que ce nouveau statut de papa va m'empêcher de faire des vidéos hein
ne ne crovez pas ça au contraire ça me donne plein d'idées, d'énergie créative
donc restez connecté il ya du lourd qui va arriver et j'vais dead ça, merci pour tous vos petits messages de
félicitations etc... c'est hyper mignon évidemment ça m'a beaucoup touché donc merci beaucoup je vous fait un gros bisou et je vous dis à bientôt
moi j'aime m'occuper de mon bébé pas en plastique hein elle a besoin de son père
j'ai dit "elle" j'ai dit elle bah trop tard je l'ai dit c'est une fille